son being the right 34 minutes welcome
back to subnautica yeah that's what this
game is called
okay guy at the store told me more tips
I can actually go in the [ __ ] what I
need to make some batteries so I can
power up my machinery so we can go there
faster yes yes you are hungry Taylor
Swift I get it all right we need some
buttholes okay let's just go make some
buttholes are they're right here
excellent block block block block
apparently you can go 3,000 meters deep
in this game
what not good don't burn face look at
our beautiful base look at it it's
beautiful enter I thought you used
copper is that oh I have gold ores these
are gold oh my god I made them all into
wires I'm an idiot okay we have some
copper nice it's as exciting for you are
you enjoying adventures will begin relax
take two buttholes and then one copper
and then you get batteries and then we
could do with some water as well
actually all right we need some coral
tubes the hell what was that
oh here we go I thought what
No all right I guess not it's pretty
nice now we don't have to go back to the
surface every time can just go back to
home how does that work
top 10 scientists cannot explain here we
go okay that timer is going down pretty
quick maybe I should just go there I
don't know how far is it it's a thousand
meters that's not that shut up it's not
that far
all right all right we're preparing
stuff okay we're good on we're good on
items in fact we're we were better than
good we're great so it's 800 meters so
we have 26 minutes though that's plenty
time I will still go there now because
I'm a coward who knows maybe we find
cool stuff on the way you know I'm
saying okay creepy green Oh make a sound
I don't like you I don't like you
whoa yes rich whoa whoa stop it
rich rich Oh God I'm already full
hey I'm rich don't touch me can't touch
rich people everyone know this Sunbeam
mining site where it's that oh we're
here we're running out of battery then
I'm not a big fan of this place not
gonna lie all right can we scan this
nice because apparently I can enter the
ship which is what I want to do it's
just that and there's a ton of stuff to
scan there as well
I want the Atty tape all right not that
close I guess I can drink some oh my god
so much titanium maybe I over prepared a
little bit here
well what hello what I'm a land Hey
there better not be Tigers or something
stupid what in the world is that
hey spiders no I say no just headcrabs
go back to half-life go back to
half-life I don't like spiders in video
games I like spiders in real life I
don't like liars thank you thank you
hey what's this dish can't scan it all
right this is kind of weird did not oh
look at that table flag lumen I would
take a long time to scan Oh purple
tablet yeah yeah oh oh I insert the
tablet oh it's in
I'm infected I'm sure that's fine
insert tablet thought I had it then I
know how I'm AI have to make it right I
have to make it oh maybe I have to that
means I have to hurry back back in water
so in since when can I mark where my
basis there has to be a way to do what
is this Wow oh my god oh my god on a
pole I need gold meters oxygen
efficiency decreased no I don't like
this you pokemon it no one likes folk
can't him everyone likes poker leave me
alone
[Music]
I'm just a guy trying to chill in the
water yes I peed a little bit but that
is no excuse to hurt them man I can make
a purple tablet yeah I need an ion cube
how do I get that man okay I guess we
can build the house a little bit yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah while we wait for a
bit say why not just flex on our house
will obey you no I'm saying I extend it
ooh yeah let's make a little L here yeah
yeah I'm building and building we can
make it in shape of PP I like that idea
[Music]
look at that it's so spacious now all I
ever wanted was a what's an aquarium but
for some reason I can't build it and
it's so unfair oh god I'm really
crunching for time now
where's my bass okay okay we have time
we have time we have time we have time
we have time wait time time time time
okay I want to make before I leave on
this epic a parent finder tool
yes baby yes baby sexist Texas drop me
and you do that kind of a favor think
about the budget sorry I got a little
excited
okay so can I place this here now how
does this work because I'm tired of no
shut up oh is that it
hopefully okay cool
I don't think that's what it's for but
whatever we're going here now can I see
it still not really it's so ecstatic
this game the colors and everything I
love it love love love the colors oh
don't think look at that can I do it
dolphin help that's so cool thank you
guys for commenting how cool I was thank
you what's this
Radio 8 Dave yeah that's a word yeah we
got a radio 8 Dave over here all right
let's check out this thing hey it's a
cube connected to 2 and then more oh wow
[Music]
can I explore inside oh maybe I find
secret entrance
yeah here it is found it all right maybe
not maybe not okay now we play a waiting
game
maybe we can summit the mountain or
something epic how about that Hey look
at that I found another one
what are you kidding me I could all
right let's put it in goddamn it covers
and we'll all cat can I jump from here
yeah I'm sure I can yeah look at that
did it tablet in I don't premiere and
third look at that spaceship hanged
alright alright and I go in they go
hello
scans indicate this structure is
composed of a metal alloy with
unprecedented integrity very much is
founded did she just say the holing
structural analysis hey hey a quick in
and out as I like to say let's go hey
who's here hey hey
is anyone here I need the green one over
here gamers I think I know how to make
the green one right it's a it's the
jacksepticeye one right speaking Gaelic
I bet no one understands that I mean I
don't even understand Irish really
download it then you dumb schmuck
we got all kinds of stuff happening down
there okay what this this a we found a
septic I at last mine hey I've been
looking for this yay tell you more green
stuff mine what is now I can't go there
I have a spaceship waiting for me three
minutes no this is making me anxious I
kind of want to check this out though
what if there's something epic what what
okay
all right we got to go back take me back
[Music]
look at that
it's like swimming in the air also known
as flying yeah I invented it hey pop pop
pop pop how was that pop pop pop pop
yeah yeah yeah
two minutes Oh God all right take me out
I'm done I'm done with this place I got
the green cubes I got the green cubes I
beat the game guys finally better that
took longer than I thought but I beat
the game pretty fast I would say all
right we should be able to see this
spaceship right now
coming right in gamers in time to have
some candy albula and soft perfect I'll
go on top of this just to show him alpha
okay we got their eye on Q what can I
make with iron cube I'm sure there's
something right something Epica oh oh oh
ayan cube come on give me something cool
something cool gamers have I not made
these I think I can make these I should
make those later remind me remind me
because I you know I forget I swear I
saw something with that green
jacksepticeye blue yeah I can make a
purple tablet now why would I make that
when I found one stupid vodka
okay ready to be saved is that spaceship
I think it is it's coming right in it's
flapping its wings same oh it's
butterfly hello
maybe I shouldn't write help or
something on the beach so they know I'm
here
well that's trippy dude oh what a oh
wait oh it does it does that I didn't I
didn't know it did I it's it's supposed
to do that
[Music]
survivor we see you man I don't know how
you help out down there we broke an
atmosphere and we're descending towards
the landing site all right I'll see an
agenda building down there what do you
mean oh oh I believe most everyone
touching down in ten nine eight it's
coming from the building change course
set thrusters before they're all dead
look at the butterfly dude it's awesome
look at that oh my god they got freaking
pulverize dude you just got smoked out
of the muck him all right
what are the odds what are the odds okay
all right well time to explore
jacksepticeye castle I knew there'd be
something here I knew it I just flip and
dippin
finger-licking take this squishing knew
it all right whoever is in charge of the
machine they're in the air you're gonna
be really really sad because you just
killed my teams hello I have a
flashlight and I'm not afraid to blind
your eyes
seriously could cause a lot of damage I
just demonstrated the dump separates
lives inside these quarters they can
only speak one language all right
where's the elevator airless airavata
or nobody must all right
smooth as poo yeah I said yeah okay I'm
all right so swim degrees I knew there
was a secret entrance hole I knew it man
I could've just swam inside see really
that locomotive is all right well there
was something over here wasn't anything
Oh 360 hop 360 huh hmm
what is it is we can make their
technology yes
I'll steal it check set the cube more so
we can go up here
Hey oh so that's why we need to make
another one nevermind we can just grab
it cool a scan is Kenny doomsday device
sounds pretty 2020 to me okay do I put
this here
I don't premiere I enter you
come on let's let me thank you I wonder
if my suit is dried or if I'm still
moist you know what I mean I put my
peepee in there do it always put peepee
in oh my god what is jacksepticeye well
I'm glad I input people
self scan translation reads warning
infected individuals may not disable the
weapon this planet is under quarantine
self scan complete he's progressing
detecting skin irritation and immune
system response further data required to
identify bacterial strain translating
background broadcast downloading summary
to databank
so I guess we'll just come back here I'm
not touching PP again well come back
here once I figure out how to not be
infected and stuff I have a feeling I
should not or jump down there Oh broke
my legs it's whatever all right we could
also go down here I remember yeah it was
in here
cool room pretty cool scanning all right
we're getting old conscious that I swear
there was another door with a purple
tablet oh my god it's all dark now super
spooky Dookie hello tree I think that
went well besides you know the giant
ship thing but quiet headcrab no one's
speaking to you
wish I had a friend at least you know
that wasn't a headcrab not talking to
you a night swim let's go
this game is comfy it's very comfy
that's the word for it
it feels good men I can't see a goddamn
thing but you know hello I'm not going
forward I'm swimming into a rock I am an
actual idiot let's go back to our pod
really quick we haven't been there in a
while cool there's nothing new epic
Power Cell high-capacity mobile power
source oh nice I guess I need that for
like submarine since then alright we go
into the spaceship now can I make the
super Finn's or whatever so I first need
to make fence what could be much but
fins there you go
and then I make super fans do I have a
lithium I feel like I do or should I
call it feeling hacking lit right now
titanium the rehab titanium we do bro oh
yeah we can make it if we try how do I
make them at the modification station
what the hell is that mother gave you
they dad I can't even build a query a
modification station shush modification
station holdup mence
no I haven't unlocked that yet I will
drink people are they rotten
[Music]
come on forgot you have to eat them
right away
all right spaceship Akim us I need some
fish first I actually look
look
click check
check
kick ass up tanks way looking good
tonight girl
alright so apparently if you go on the
side you can enter I don't know if that
means the front through the back but I'm
guessing the front whoa yeah trooper
phobia yeah I can make except the guy
things now oh my god I'm rich dude
forgot how much stuff there are over
here look at this look at this what in
the snake I'm sure it's fine bro look at
this
so all shaky it's a little stable
these things happen alright there's got
to be an entrance oh no all right can
you stop shaking nope did shop guy lie
to me okay not my problem I'm not the
[ __ ] by my she's like yet the laser
cutter I don't have the laser cutter yet
it's fine it's stable everyone knows
it's stable it's been there for a
hundred years I don't think it's gonna
just crash all of a sudden all right
where's the entrance
this is normal it's normal no reason to
panic no panic no panic no Spanish am I
right gamers oh yeah good the double
game
oh can I scan this
I run out of battery now
fresh air life is great I love the lands
of the man
I'm never going water again
and go to the share piece and stinky oh
god what the hell I peepee penty oh my
god
I don't like this game when it does that
I don't like the game when it does that
I have to go in the water again I have
to go in the water again look at that
that's great yeah I'll just go in the
water again why not why would I not
there go in that water again stop it
okay all right we'll just swim here
I'm sure it's gone I'm sure it's gone
I'm sure it's gone it's gone it's gone
it's gone it's gone I think it's gone
yeah I'm sure it's gone it's gone for
sure for sure it's gone for sure it's
gone
it's gone it's gone it's gone it's gone
there's gone it's gone
like my son hid then run yeah yeah he's
gone it's gone we're safe you're safe
super safe never felt so safe in these
waters where's their mother flippin
entrance I don't like these murky waters
I don't I don't like it
ah the entrance I found it yes I'm gonna
go ahead and let me say there's no
interest and I'd be trolled and I've
been tricked into getting asked blob to
buy a freaking demon so thanks for that
what is this okay I scan you you're
scanned now okay
need more of those kind of hard to
navigate in there page darkness I need
to find my base yeah there it is home
sweet the mother flipping home gamers I
think we can build a little bit on it
can make another hatch
nice nice
[Music]
through the lockers great feelings oh
yeah oh yeah yeah look at that all right
look get that look at that a window I
got a freaking window they're amazed
that's cool all right I'm gonna end that
episode there if you enjoyed support
this show smash like subscribe and by
the merch
Hado see you tomorrow